so now armed you've broken so many rules
since you've been in here I'm sorry
when I walked in i felt like it was
races how much should I take my shoes
off and then as soon as I said that went
fine yeah that's racist and can I say
that and I'll tell you why you are like
this you're like this because you walk
around in life you know you're a winner
okay like cancer you ask me yeah you
know you're a good-looking guy you're a
bigger in Statuary like the bane of
comedy you know
the muscle back muscles right I could
play game brother he's he's successful
in all these little arenas that he goes
into right he did the UFC you know and
then he goes when he woke up one day I
wanna do comedy and do podcasting he did
that killed it on that and this is the
kind of trickster this fat that fat
thick thick thick II you know he's got a
thick dick you got thick head
yep everything about him is thick I
guess that's true but he's also a
deceiver how so I'll tell you how um you
didn't do my podcast for a little when I
started it and then one day you came out
to me it goes what am I gonna do
reporter as you kind of gave me [ __ ]
about it correct right at The Comedy
Store great what else you remember that
you remember I remember this so then I
go holy [ __ ] we gotta get him on and how
many times have I asked you to be on
this since then here's the problem Bob
no no let's answer the question first
multiple times multiple times there's
your thing
Monday night night what the [ __ ] man
Monday night what I got a three year old
I could be playing grab-ass with you on
a Monday night
you have children yeah I got three year
old men yeah
oh [ __ ] if I'm not working I'm at home
with the kid oh man I know but Monday
night is here you Monday night
what does nobody loves me my song is
bunch mob on Monday night scissors
Sunday night just Monday Night Football
I all right all right
so that said you have children yeah and
then it's at night too so it's a bit of
a B so I went if you can move it up I'm
here but you do stand-up at night - not
on Mondays yeah but you do it Sundays
and Mondays my only two days all those
are the two ones
oh so you're you look at it as like a
Monday through Wednesday five day a job
correct
we've been Mondays now Monday days are
packed because I record two podcasts to
show with uh the Rat King nope I do
below the belt which is just me for
Showtime then I do firing the kid with
Brian whoo so the Rat King deceived you
know mean him do that on Tuesdays oh you
still do I thought he had [ __ ] you
right now yeah this so about him prepare
yourself yeah he's not crazy prepare
yourself
I love theof on but there's stuff going
on beneath the eyes the dark arts is
what he calls it I call it the dark arts
as well
okay um he's getting big
is he an famous yeah selling tickets on
the road I know he might do some things
that are very Dane Cook ish although
don't we love them before they cook 15
years ago oh [ __ ] dumb out the myspace
stink yeah yeah here we go Brandon there
you go right
[Music]